proceedings for a ministerial statement
i call it secretary of state for health
sergeant javid
thank you madam deputy speaker
me with permission i'd like to update
the house on code 19 but before i begin
i want to wish the shadow secretary of
state well as he recovers from kobit 19.
madam deputy speaker
over the past 48 hours a small number of
cases of a new variant have been
detected on our international genomic
database
i want to reassure this house that there
are no detected cases of this variant in
the uk at this time
but this new variant is of huge
international concern
the world health organization has called
a special meeting this morning and that
meeting is taking place right now
i want to update the house on what we
know so far
why we're concerned and the action that
we are taking
although i must stress
that this is a fast-moving situation and
there remains a high degree of
uncertainty
the sequence of this variant currently
called
b11529
was first uploaded by hong kong from a
case of someone traveling from south
africa
the uk was the first country to identify
the potential threat of this new variant
and to alert international partners
further cases have been identified in
south africa
and in botswana and it is highly likely
that it is now spread to other countries
yesterday the south african government
held a press conference where they
provided an update on what they know so
far
i want to put on record my thanks to
south africa not only for their rigorous
scientific response
but the openness and transparency with
which they have acted
much as we did here in the united
kingdom when we first detected what is
now known as the alpha variant
madam deputy speaker
we are concerned that this new variant
may pose substantial risk to public
health
the variant has an unusually large
number of mutations
yesterday the uk health security agency
classified b11529
as a new variant under investigation
and the variant technical group has
designated it as a variant under
investigation with very high priority
it's the only variant with this
designation making it higher priority
than beta
it shares many of the features of alpha
beta and delta variants
early indications show
this variant may be more transmissible
than the delta variant
and current vaccines may be less
effective against it
it may also impact the effectiveness of
one of our major treatments ronaprief
madam deputy speaker
we're also worried about the rising
cases in countries in southern africa
especially as these populations should
have significant natural immunity
in south africa in particular
there has been exponential growth with
cases increasing fourfold over the last
two weeks
in gaoteng province which includes
johannesburg and pretoria some eighty
percent of cases when tested with a pcr
test have shown something that is known
as the s gene dropout
which we associate with this variant
so while we don't know yet definitively
whether the exponential growth in south
africa is directly associated with this
new variant
this pcr test analysis does indicate
that there could be many more cases of
this new variant than just those that
have been sequenced so far
so madam deputy speaker
even as we continue to learn more about
this new variant one of the lessons of
this pandemic has been that we must move
quickly and at the earliest possible
moment
the uk remains in a strong position
we've made tremendous gains as a result
of the decisions that we took over the
summer and the initial success of our
booster program
but we're heading into winter and our
booster program is still ongoing so we
must act with caution
so we're taking the following steps
yesterday i announced that from midday
today we're placing cis countries in
southern africa on the travel red list
these countries are south africa
botswana le cetu eswatini namibia and
zimbabwe
anyone who is not a uk or irish resident
who has been in one of these countries
in the last 10 days will be denied entry
into england
uk and irish residents arriving from
these countries from 4 am on sunday will
enter hotel quarantine
anyone arriving before
then before those dates should take pcr
tests on day 2 and day 8 even if they
are vaccinated and isolate at home
along with the rest of their household
if you've arrived from any of these
countries in the last 10 days nhs test
and traced will be contacting you and
asking you to take pcr tests
but please do not wait to be contacted
you should take pcr tests
right away
we've been working closely with the
devolved administrations on this and
they will be aligning their response
in recent hours israel has also taken
similar precautions
madam deputy speaker i wish to stress
that we're working quickly and we're
working with a high degree of
uncertainty
we are continuing to make assessments
including about those countries with
strong travel links to south africa
and we are working with our
international partners including south
africa and the european union to ensure
an aligned response
but this variant is a reminder for all
of us that this pandemic is far from
over
we must continue to act with caution and
do all we can to keep this virus at bay
including
once you are eligible
getting your booster shot
we've already given over 16 million
booster shots the booster jab was
already important before we knew about
this variant but now
it could not be more important
so please
if you are eligible get your booster
shot do not delay
madam deputy speaker we've made great
progress against this virus progress
that we are determined to hold on to
this government will continue to do
whatever is necessary to keep us safe
and we've all got our part to play i
commend this statement to the house
alex morris
thank you madam dr speaker
statement and for his kind words about
the shadow secretary of state which we
would all share on this side of the
house too
now we have been critical of the
government in the past for taking too
long to protect our borders from new
variants particularly when delta was
left to run free so we are glad to see
swift action today adding these
countries to the red list is the right
call and we support it
uh i wonder if the secretary of state
might explain why it's these specific
countries added and not the wider group
where cases of this variant have been
detected and whether the addition of
further countries is under active
consideration over the coming days but
that perhaps in the meantime we might at
least for countries not on the red list
but have cases require pcr tests on
arrival rather than lateral flow ones
and we have made us the secretary of
state says great strides in getting
people vaccinated in this country but
we've always warned that no one will be
safe until everyone is safe and it's
regrettable that when we offered plans
to the government earlier around global
expansion of vaccination those weren't
taken up and today's news does reflect a
failure of the global community to
distribute the vaccine with just 5.5
percent of people in low-income
countries being vaccinated so could the
secretary of state tell us about the
work he'll be doing with his
counterparts in affected countries to
make sure that they have the vaccines
and the infrastructure to deliver them
and can he give us the assurance that
our cuts to aid that we've made in this
country will not affect affects that and
would he would he share with us our
regret that we have to destroy 600 000
expired doses of the vaccine in august
and what we're making what we're doing
to make sure our stockpiles get to other
countries who need them
turning to testing modern deputy speaker
earlier this month capacity went down
significantly with members of the public
reporting that their local centers had
closed would the secretary of state
reassure us that testing still will be
an integral part of our approach and can
he take this opportunity
to refute the rumors that test and trace
will be scaled down further
this is also a reminder madam deputy
speaker we need to go further and faster
with vaccination at home children's
vaccination rates remain low the
progress on the booster is of course
welcome but we know to get there by
christmas we need to go even quicker and
there are of course huge pockets of the
country where significant numbers of
people remain unvaccinated 40 of people
for example in nottingham 38 in one's
worth 30
in bolton and the message that secretary
of state had for those people today i
think was a very important one
because this is a reminder that covert
has not gone away so will the secretary
of state make commitments to fix sick
pay fix sick pay which is still
necessary 19 months on and will he go
further to ensure that public buildings
schools and businesses have the support
they need and surely madam deputy
speaker we must now revisit cost-free
measures such as mask wearing in public
spaces
madame madden deputy speaker to conclude
this is a sobering reminder of the
challenges that this pandemic brings and
we must meet this moment as we have
throughout the last 19 months
by pulling together by looking out for
each other and in that british spirit of
doing what must be done thank you
secretary of state
well deputies became pleased to respond
to the shadow minister his f his first
question was around the the countries
the six countries uh that we have um
decided to put on the red list from
midday today
we are going by uh primarily about where
these new variant has been detected at
this point and that's been confirmed in
in two countries in southern africa and
that's south africa and uh botswana uh
we've included the four other countries
that i mentioned earlier uh in in
southern africa uh as a precaution uh
and uh i think the the shadow minister
won't be surprised to know that we are
keeping this under a review and there's
very live discussions going on around
whether we should and when we might add
further countries and we won't hesitate
to act if we need to do so
in terms of the vaccine donations to
developing uh countries uh the shadows
is absolutely right about the importance
of this uh he will know uh that the uk
uh has for a country of its size has
done far more than any other country in
the world already over 30 million
donations we're absolutely committed to
our 100 million uh target and we will
continue to work bilaterally with
countries but also through the kovacs
alliance uh to to get out more vaccines
to the developing world
testing remains a hugely important part
of our response to this pandemic it's
playing a a a a
incredibly important role and that will
continue for as long as is necessary and
then lastly on on the vaccinations of
course that is the primary force the the
primary form of defense uh in our
country in in one sense we are fortunate
with such a high level of vaccination uh
over 80 percent of people over the age
of 12 have been double vaccinated 88 at
least a single vaccination that's won
the highest in the world but uh we need
to go further and we need to go even
faster and it is great news that our
booster program at over 16 million jobs
across the uk is the most successful in
europe uh now i believe over 26 percent
of the population over the age of uh 12
but we would want more and more people
to come forward as soon as they're
eligible and i can't stress the
importance of that enough and today as
he said at the end of his remarks it is
a sober reminder that we are still
fighting this pandemic and we can all
play a part
dr liam fox deputy speaker the viral
mutation process of genetic drift
depends on the number of times a virus
gets to replicate so the wider the
spread geographically and the longer
that it goes on the more viral
replications will occur and the more
chances there will be for mutations so
there is a need to redouble our efforts
to vaccinate populations right across
the globe my right honorable friend
mentioned the potential increased
transmissibility
of this virus but there's another
important element which is the severity
of the illness produced by a variant
what do we know about it so far and the
potential therefore for impact on the
health service
socio states and the please speak as
always the analysis that provided by my
right honourable friend is absolutely
correct in terms of the severity uh of
this uh new variant i'm afraid we don't
know enough yet uh the from from what we
can tell from a a let's call it a
desktop analysis uh given the number of
mutations that have been identified and
you double those that were there for the
delta variant uh it does indicate uh
that there's a possibility uh
that it it might have a different impact
on an individual should they get
infected but
as i said earlier there's a lot we don't
know about this and we are working with
our international partners to find out
more
rachel maskel
thank you madame dr speaker i thank the
secretary of state for his statement
today and also for emphasizing the
importance of vaccination however
his statement does make clear that we
are seeing new variants and the risks
still remain and therefore taking
further public health measures is really
really important and therefore i ask him
again whether or not he can give very
clear leadership around ensuring that
face coverings social distancing and
high hygiene are
instituted as well as better ventilation
because these measures do make a
difference as we've seen throughout the
last two years
the honourable lady makes a good point
about the the need uh to to follow
guidance and uh the rules that are
currently in place uh the the plan a uh
policies that we put in place they
remain uh the policies i think that that
we need at this time but she won't be
surprised to know that we do keep this
under review and if we need to go
further we will
so charles walker
honorable gentleman opposite the shadow
spokesman for for for her majesty's
opposition mentioned the number of
people who are unvaccinated please
secretary of state can we bring a nasal
vaccine to market stage 2 trials are
proving to be really really good and
positive with high rates of efficacy if
we've got to throw the kitchen sink at
this i cannot understand why we are not
making nasal vaccines available that
will increase the uptake of vaccination
in this country and across europe
it's actually a state my honorable
friend is absolutely right to point to
the importance of the the continued
imports of the vaccination program and
there are some five million people in
the uk that haven't even received a
single shot of any type of vaccine he's
right to to talk about the importance of
the methods of delivery of a vaccine and
as he's uh mentioned there are trials of
nasal vaccines uh but he i'm sure he'll
understand until uh the such vaccines
are approved by our independent
regulator we would not be able to pursue
them
thank you madam deputy speaker i'd like
to thank the secretary of state and the
nhs and everyone who is responsible for
the booster program that's helping to
protect us as we enter the winter months
but isn't one of the lessons of the news
that he's announced today
that if we don't
tackle the enormous vaccine inequality
around the world we're going to continue
to be exposed to new variants of this
type
in africa for example just 6.6 of the
population have been vaccinated now of
course it's every government's first
duty to protect its own people everyone
understands that but does the secretary
of state agree that the united kingdom
and other rich countries in the world
must do more to ensure that surplus
doses
that we don't need are distributed to
countries that do need them
rather than not being used and
ultimately in some cases being destroyed
and deputy speaker i very much agree
with uh every word of the uh on awards
gentlemen uh especially around the the
surplus vaccines and and that is exactly
what we have done
whenever we have identified vaccines
that we may not need uh we have offered
them either bilaterally or through the
kovacs program and we will absolutely
continue to play our role but also very
importantly we will continue to urge our
international partners to do all they
can as well
john loud
thank you very very much i
can commend the government for the speed
at which they have taken and this
decision i also welcomed the fact that
the scottish government is following and
so because nepal has been concerned
about the lack of consistency across the
uk but does the health
secretary agree with me but this is a
useful reminder that the pandemic is
still with us and we all have a
responsibility to get vaccinated and
that includes getting the booster
social statements i mean first uh i can
tell my honorable friend that there's
been excellent coordination uh across
the uk uh
on this and as i mentioned earlier that
scotland and all parts of the uk will be
aligning themselves with uh what i have
announced uh but the importance of the
booster program as i say cannot be more
important in fact the very latest
figures are 28.5
of the uk population of the age of 12
has been boosted more than by far and
away more than any other country in
europe i think second only to the united
states but it's still not enough we need
everyone to come forward and if there
are people
out there listening that are thinking
what can they do the single most
important thing they can do is if they
are eligible for booster go and get it
in fact go out this weekend and make it
your booster weekend
meg hilliar thank you madam deputy
speaker
speaker i appreciate that the secretary
of state has come to the house at the
earliest opportunity and his swift
action and i hope this indicates the way
he will engage with us all on this vital
issue i wonder if he's had any
indication from south africa and the
other south african nations of southern
africa that he mentioned about the
impact of on children of this variant
and whether there are any plans to offer
second doses to children here in the uk
madam deputy speaker it's a
it's a very good question for the
honourable lady and then i mean first of
all i have to at this point in time this
has moved so fast we have not had any
indications about the potential impact
of this uh new variant on on children in
particular uh it is something as soon as
we can find out we will want to share uh
in terms of the uk the the child
vaccination program uh it is going well
across the uk it's been building up a
significant momentum but as for whether
second doses
would be recommended we would await for
the expert advice of the jcvi
suzanne webb
thank you mr speaker i welcome the
swiftness of the government's response
to this new variant under investigation
can my right honourable friend confirm
that as the situation develops the
government will continue to move at the
earliest possible opportunity
session state yes i can absolutely make
that commitment to my uh honorable
friend and and she will
perhaps know already from the
information the government shared we we
only uh identified the significance of
this variant uh just two or three days
ago and uh we we didn't hesitate to take
action because as we've always said we
will protect our borders when it comes
to this pandemic
lily in greenwood
speaker as the secretary of state has
reiterated getting vaccinated
is vitally important i'm looking forward
to getting my booster jab
tomorrow but he knows that some groups
and some communities are more hesitant
more fearful about being vaccinated and
i'm really conscious both that
vaccination rates in nottingham city are
below those in the wider county and that
our local health services are already
under huge pressure so can the secretary
of state set out what he's doing to
drive up vaccination rates in areas
where there's been low take-up and will
he now offer places like nottingham
additional support as we head into
winter
state
madame deaf speaker i want to make sure
all the support that is needed for our
vaccination program is there across uh
england and uh
and she asks the honorable lady quite
rightly what are we doing to reach out
to those that have for whatever reason
so far been a bit hesitant we are
working actively now for months with
many community leaders we have added
many more uh venues and ways to actually
receive the vaccine so improved access
and uh there's significant work on on
communications and reaching out and
making sure the right messages are there
and also people available including
clinicians to to answer questions and
but she's absolutely right to point to
the importance of this and i uh i'm
pleased to hear that she'll be getting
boosted this weekend
mr christopher chu
speaker ivan
has
shown promising results as a potential
treatment for covid19 including in south
africa
over five months ago ivamektin was added
to the oxford university trial called
principle
when will the results of that trial be
available and what is the government
doing to expedite the process because
either mechanic may not be a magic
bullet but it may be
social state friend makes a a very
important point there
the one thing that is different about
dealing with this pandemic today than
even a year ago is that we already do
have more treatments and my honourable
friend mentions
another potential new treatment um i'm
afraid there is no um
exact date that i can share with him but
when we think the trials will be over
but i'm pleased that these trials are
taking place he's right to point out
the potential of this treatment and but
i i can reassure him that whether it's
with either mectin or other potential
new treatments uh the uk could not be
more engaged
ruth jones
thank you madam deputy speaker and i
thank the secretary of state for coming
to the house today to give us this
statement so so urgently there were a
number of high-profile sporting events
due to have taken place in south africa
this coming weekend including the united
rugby championship in which cardiff and
the scarlet rugby teams are due to play
so what assistance has been given to
them to get them home ahead of the
midday deadline today and also what
discussions has the secretary of state
had with the devolved administration to
ensure a coordinated orderly
introduction of the new travel
restrictions
secretary of state so the round deposit
first why i understand whether it's
sports teams or
the thousands of british tourists and
others that are currently find
themselves in south africa botswana or
any of these countries
this this is very difficult news but i
but i hope that many will understand
indeed i've had messages today from
people that are in south africa and it's
made their life a bit more difficult
getting back home but they fully
understand and support the action that
has been taken as for her particular
question around the team and and what um
what can be done to try and get them
back uh before this deadline nothing we
won't do anything to help them get back
before this deadline because i think
anyone who's in south africa
the best thing to do is to come back and
you after 4 a.m on sunday and go into
hotel quarantine
mark palsy thank you
speaker may i commend the secretary of
state for the extremely prompt action
that he's taking to protect our citizens
and while these are very early days the
secretary of state himself has spoken
about the uncertainty and that we don't
know enough about the new variment
variant does he have any assessment of
how long the measures that he has
introduced has announced might be
necessary
it's actually a state
it is a good question madam speaker but
i'm afraid that the such is the
uncertainty
around this variant and and and the rate
at which it is um seems to be spreading
i'm afraid
it's not possible to put a timeline on
this action
guys thomas
speaker if we're to help reduce the
chance of further variants emerging to
threaten the health of our citizens
we need to clearly accelerate
vaccination programs in other countries
particularly in the commonwealth
so why are ministers so determined to
use the world trade organization
ministerial meeting next week to block
progress towards achieving as south
africa and india want a temporary waiver
of intellectual property rules to help
developing countries develop their own
vaccine manufacturing capacity
so state
the answer to the honorable gentleman is
because a a temporary waiver of
intellectual
property for such purposes it would be a
huge step backwards it won't help
developing countries it certainly won't
help
if we do need new vaccines not just for
kobit 19 but for a future pandemic that
the industry and the business might step
back and not bother developing if they
believe that their intellectual property
would always be waived in such
circumstances what is important and i
think the honourable gentleman would
agree on this is that uh the the the
companies that are developing these
life-saving vaccines
have an appropriate pricing and access
policy for each country so if they are
dealing with developing countries that
is priced appropriately in an accessible
way and countries rich countries like
the uk the us and others continue to do
all they can
through international vaccine donation
programs
phillip hollerberg
swift actions taken in relation to this
new
variant and he's completely right that
the booster program is now more
important than ever but in the kettering
constituency residents in rothwell
desperate burton latimer barton seagrave
and kettering are telling me of the
difficulty they're experiencing in
getting a booster within the kettering
constituency and they're being asked to
go to either corby or northampton which
for many people is very difficult so can
we have a boost to the booster program
in kettering with uh immediately local
walk-in booster centers yeah secretary
of state my honorable friend is right to
talk about the the ease of access to the
booster program and of course we want to
make it as easy as possible we are
adding
numerous sites day by day
but on the particular issue around
kettering i i will absolutely see what
we can do the vaccines minister has
heard what my honourable friend has said
and uh if i may if i can suggest they
can have a quick meet after this and and
i'm sure she's uh really eager to open
up more access points and kettering
karen mccarthy madame deputy speaker i
would echo what the honourable member
for kettering said i got my booster on
18th of december which a few days ago
was the first date that was being
offered near me in bristol but can i ask
there's a growing divide now between
people who
um will have had three jabs and people
who won't have been jabbed at all what
more can we do to persuade i know
there's some hardcore vaccine few snicks
but there's also quite a lot of people
that think that because they've had a
mild dose of covid they're now immune
and particularly new variants coming on
board we know that they could well be at
risk so what can we do to persuade those
people that have not been jabbed at all
that it's time to get jabbed
social stage
the honourable ladies is absolutely
right they are they're
still too many people out there that
that are let's call vaccine hesitant and
they're not complete refuse things they
just would want more information and
maybe they've read the wrong
type of information and uh and more
needs to be continuously done to reach
out to them so
whether they're if there are people in
particular communities we are working
with community leaders there's been a
real change in our comms program trying
to reach out to people in different ways
for example much more use of uh of
social media uh and and also through our
uh general uh comms if the honourable
lady also uh has some
new ideas and she thinks that we can try
we are listening
speaker and can i also welcome the speed
in which the government has acted uh
many caution and wellington residents
have contacted me before to raise
concerns about people rushing to fly to
the uk before added to the red list so
can i write another nothing confirm that
flights from these six countries will be
banned until the quarantine is
introduced on sunday and that this same
policy will apply to any new countries
being added to the red list in the
future
secretary of state yet the uh what i can
tell my old friend that the decision to
to ban the flights uh it's obviously
it's a temporary ban is uh to allow us
time to stand up the the quarantine
system the red list system what's called
the managed quarantine system and once
that system uh starts and we are
comfortable that is functioning as we
would like then
then those
your flights that we would review uh
that decision um
and so if it comes to any other country
we would consider uh banning flights if
for similar reasons as has been
taken here that it's necessary
greg smith thank you uh madam deputy
speaker my right-hand friend is
absolutely right to be taking these new
variants as seriously as he is but given
the critical importance of avoiding the
damage to children's education
development and the economic havoc more
lockdowns would bring if the news from
our world-class scientists analyzing our
current vaccines effectiveness against
these new variants is positive
what assessment is my writable friend
made of the ability to stretch the
booster program to bring it down through
the age categories and to get it into
more arms potentially quicker than the
six-month gap
as we head into winter
state the mandeville could mean
regardless of the the the news around
this very the booster program remains
absolutely crucial and in fact if
anything because of this news as i said
earlier it's even more important and my
honorable friend asks
you
about whether the program may be
extended uh to lower age categories and
as he knows from this monday we extend
it to the age group 40 to 49 that is
something that the jcbi has already said
that they are considering and i await
their advice
thank you i thank the secretary of state
for having come directly to the house
this morning order
order
ah we return now
to the down syndrome bill
and as i just hesitate for a moment to
allow people to leave the chamber
tom randall
thank you madam deputy speaker
and
like many others i rise to speak in
support of this bill and i'd like to add
my congratulations as they've been from
across the house to the right honourable
member for for north somerset on
bringing this bill uh to the house and
uh for his passionate speech um in in
favor of the measures um that are
contained uh within it um down syndrome
um is a visible condition and the name
will be uh familiar to very many people
but um
i think what um his speech did this
morning was to actually raise so much
awareness of a condition which
so many factors of which we